this week we have a great video question
from reader Robin Kaiser when travelling
in Europe can I text people in America
without incurring charges and if not
what kind of arrangements do I need to
make Robin your vacation sounds like a
lot of fun what's not fun are the
charges you could come home to if you
start text messaging when you're away
carriers can charge an arm and a leg for
international service even for those
short texts but before you leave if you
sign up for one of their international
texting plans or at least one of the
bundled plans that includes
international texting you could save a
lot of money
check your carrier's websites for
international options and read the fine
print many of those carrier plans are
just for texting and don't include data
charges you'd incur if you were using
other apps and unless you sign up for an
international data package those data
overages could crush you that's why I
suggest turning off data just use
messaging apps like whatsapp or kick to
chat and share photos over Wi-Fi apps
like viber and Skype even let you make
calls over Wi-Fi and most hotels have
wireless and same with most coffee shops
you can turn off data on your iPhone by
going to settings then to the cellular
switch and then switching off cellular
data and LTE Android users can turn off
data by going to settings then data
usage and switching off mobile data of
course we're not going on vacation we're
always here so send us your tech
questions on Twitter and Facebook with
the hashtag SW SJD or email them to us
at personal tech at wsj.com